good morning Hank it's Tuesday your
video on Friday reminded me that we
don't talk enough about joy or the many
very real reasons to feel joyous by the
way I didn't get a haircut I'm too busy
let's not talk about that let's talk
about joy here's the thing Hank I think
it's really hard to feel joy unless you
make room for it which might be one of
the reasons that historically humans
have created so many celebration rituals
from coming-of-age ceremonies to yay it
rained ceremonies we have created all of
these occasions for us to come together
and feel joy or at least we used to
create them but these days of course
fewer of us are receiving first
communion or dancing when it rains or
whatever and that can make it feel like
there is no cause for celebration
and I just don't think that's true like
at a societal level us median household
income is higher than it's ever been and
the poverty rate is declining although
not as fast as it should be given our
economic growth but still cause for
celebration and there are also of course
many personal causes for celebration
there's love among family and friends
there are babies and there are human
accomplishments big and small maybe you
got a promotion at work or passed a
class that was difficult or overcame
your anxiety to call the dealership
about that rattling noise in your car or
maybe that's just me but at any rate
it's also worth celebrating I'm also
very pleased that this year's black-eyed
pea crop almost filled this container
plus I learned how to dry oregano which
only looks illegal in 27 States and then
of course there are big things like my
daughter going to kindergarten but
whatever it is I think if you look hard
at your wife over the last several
months you will find causes for
celebration there will be
accomplishments that you're proud of or
developments that you're grateful for
and in my experience at least if you
don't pause to celebrate that stuff it's
never gonna bring you much joy in my
life anyway the weird thing is that if I
take time to celebrate
I can feel really joyful about things
that from the outside probably don't
seem that impressive like I worked my
tail off for these black-eyed peas and I
am super psyched about them but if I
don't take time to celebrate I feel
almost nothing about things that from
the outside probably seem like really
big deals like when I found out my novel
Turtles all the way down had its 50
second consecutive week on the New York
Times bestseller list I felt happy for a
moment but then I went back to feeling
the kind of broad and poorly specified
anxiety that tends to be my background
emotion it was only weeks later when
Sarah came home with a bottle of
champagne and we toasted together in a
at celebration that I suddenly felt
overwhelmed with joy and gratitude so
here's my proposal every now and again
you get a bottle of champagne you don't
need the good stuff and if you don't
drink don't get champagne get some fancy
tea or chocolate or a really great
cheese or something you love you have a
friend or two over or you gather
together your roommates or your parents
or your partner or whomever and you
break bread or pop champagne or sip tea
or whatever and you celebrate you talk
about the wonderful thing that has
happened you tell the story of how you
won that game of fortnight or you made
that student loan payment or you got
that promotion and you celebrate it
together and then you invite people to
share with you what they are celebrating
I've been doing this lately and it has
brought me so much joy and then after we
all like celebrate together for a bit we
go back to complaining about everything
because you know it's a dumpster fire
but even so I believe there is cause for
celebration so Hank here's to building
rituals and traditions that help us to
come together and celebrate I don't have
any champagne with me but I do have this
Cherry Coke Zero hash tag not spawn
Cheers
Prost 'la hi I'm Hank I'll see you on
Friday
it's pretty good cherry coke zero
actually